in its most popular sense when people
talk about mitosis they're referring to
a cell a diploid cell so diploid just
means it has its full complement of
chromosomes so it has 2n chromosomes so
that's the nucleus this is the whole
cell and so most people are saying well
if the cell itself replicates into two
diploid cells so it turns into two cells
each that have a full complement of
chromosomes 2n chromosomes and so when
people say a cell has experienced
mitosis they normally mean this but I
want to make one slight clarification
that formally mitosis only refers to the
process of the replication of the of the
genetic material and the nucleus so for
example this if I were to draw this let
me draw the cell and it has now two
nucleuses each with the diploid number
of chromosomes this cell has experienced
mitosis mitosis it has not experienced
cytokinesis which we will talk about in
a few moments but that's the process of
the actual cytoplasm of the spit of this
of the cell being split into two
different cells and just as a clarity
the cytoplasm is all the stuff outside
of the outside of the nucleus cytoplasm
so I'll talk about that in a second but
just know in everyday usage this is
normally the case when people talk about
mitosis but if you got a teacher that
likes to get you on a technicality this
is technically what mitosis is it's the
splitting of the nucleus or the
replication of the nucleus into two
separate nucleuses that's normally
accompanied by cytokinesis where the
cells were the where the cytoplasm of
the cells actually separate now with
that said let's go into the mechanics of
mitosis so the first steps that are
really necessary for mitosis actually
occur outside of mitosis when the cell
is just you know doing its day to day
life and that's during the interphase
interphase and the interphase literally
it's not a phase of mitosis
it's literally when the cell is just
living so
you know the cell let's say we have some
new cell let me do it in green so I have
some new cell here maybe this is its
nucleus
it's got 2n chromosomes and then it
grows it brings in nutrients from the
outside and builds proteins and dews
does whatever and so it grows a bit it's
obviously got its full chromosomal
complement still and then at some point
during this life cycle and I'll label
these actually so this phase in
interphase and this might not even be
covered in some biology classes but you
know it's they give it a label they call
it g1 which is really just when the cell
is growing it's just growing
accumulating materials and building
itself out and then it actually
replicates its chromosomes so you still
have a diploid number of chromosomes so
let me zoom in so let me draw this it's
called the S phase of interphase so this
is s and s is where you have replication
of the actual chromosomes once again
we're not even in mitosis yet so s you
have replication replication of your
chromosomes so if I were to zoom in on
the nucleus during the S phase if I were
to start off let me just start with some
organism that has that has two
chromosomes so let's say that at the
beginning of S phase and I lock you make
I'll draw things as chromosomes just to
make it clear that things are being
replicated so let me say it has this
chromosome right here and then it let's
say it has this chromosome right here as
it as it goes through S phase these
chromosomes replicate and I'm just
drawing the nucleus here I've zoomed in
on just this part right here where n is
one where to our full diploid complement
is two chromosomes during S phase our
chromosomes will replicate and we'll
have so that green one will completely
replicate and generate a copy of itself
and we've learned this a little bit
they're connected at the centromere
each of those copies are called
chromatids and that magenta one will do
the same thing now even though we have
here we had you can kind of say we have
two chromatids one for each chromosome
now we have four chromatids two for each
chromosome we still say we only have two
chromosomes that's its centromere right
now this occurs in the S phase and then
as you and then the cell will just
continue to grow more so you know the
cell was already big this I'll draw the
I'll focus on the cell again the cell is
already big and it gets bigger it gets
bigger and that's during the g2 phase so
it's just growing more g2 now there's
another little part of the cell that we
haven't even talked about yet but I'll
talk about it a little bit it's not you
know super duper important but this is
an idea of the centrosomes and these are
going to be very important later on when
the cell is actually dividing and those
also duplicate so let's say I have a
little centrosome here I have a little
centrosome here it has centrioles inside
it you don't have to worry too much
about that but there's these little
cylindrical looking things but I just
want to so you don't get confused if you
see the word centriole and centrosomes
not to be confused with centromeres
which are these little points where the
two chromatids attached unfortunately
they've named many things in in this
process very similarly or a lot of the
kind of parts of a cell very similarly
but you have these things called
centrosomes that are going to enter the
picture very soon that are sitting
outside of the nucleus and they also
they also replicate they also replicate
during the interphase so you had you had
one before now you have two of them and
of course they each have their two
little centrioles inside where we're not
going to focus too much on those just
yet so that's what happened in the
interphase now the cell and this is most
of the cell's life and it's kind of
growing and doing what it wants and
actually I'll make a slight point here
when I drew the DNA here I drew them as
chromosomes but the reality is is when
we're sitting in the interphase this is
not what the DNA would actually look
like the DNA if I were to actually draw
this it's in its chromatin form
it's all it's not all tightly wound like
I drew here I drew it tightly round so
that you can see that it got replicated
but the reality is is that that green
chromosome was actually it was actually
be all unwound and if you're looking at
microscope you would even have trouble
seeing it and this is its chromatin form
and when it when it and we'll talk a
little bit about where it actually
organizes itself back into a chromosome
but in this chromatin form it's just a
bunch of DNA and proteins that the DNA
is wrapped around a little bit so you
know you might have some proteins here
that the DNA is wrapped around a little
bit but if you're looking in a
microscope it just looks like a big blur
of DNA and proteins and same thing for
the magenta molecule and really for DNA
to do anything it has to be like this it
has to kind of be open to its
environment for in order for the mRNA
and the different types of different
types of helper proteins to really be
able to function with it and even for it
to be able to replicate it has to be
unwound like this in order to function
it only gets tightly wound like this
later on I just drew it like this so
really you know I had one green one of
this going to replicate to form another
green well they're going to be attached
at some point and that magenta one is
going to replicate to form another
magenta one and they'll be attached at
some point but it's not going to be
clear I just drew it this way to show
that it really happened this is the
reality it's in its chromatin form
chromatin now we're ready for mitosis so
the first stage of mitosis is
essentially let me let me draw this so
I'll draw the cell I'll draw the cell in
green and I'm going to draw the nucleus
a little bit well a lot bigger than it
normally is relative to the cell just
because at least right now a lot of the
action is going on in the nucleus so the
first stage of mitosis is the prophase
prophase prophase and these are really
just yeah I mean these are somewhat
arbitrary names that were assigned to
Supino people look to the microscope oh
you know that's a certain type of step
that we always see when a cell is when
nucleus is dividing so we'll call this
the prophase and what happens in the
prophase is that the actual the actual
the actual chromatin starts actually
turning into this type of form so I read
I just said when we're in the interface
that look of the the DNA is in this form
where it's all separated and unwound it
actually starts to wind together so this
is where you'll actually have and
remember it's already replicated the
replication happened before mitosis
begins so I had that one chromosome
there and then I have another one here
it has two sister chromatids that we'll
see soon get pulled apart now during
prophase you also start to have this
these these these centromeres up here
that I was touching on before these guys
over here they start to I I guess the
best way this to facilitate the
generation of these with what you call
microtubules and you can kind of view
these as these these sticks or these
ropes that are going to be key and
moving things around when we as we
divide the cell and all of this is
pretty amazing I mean you think of a
cell you think of something that's you
know inherently pretty simple it's a
kind of one of its kind of the most
basic living structure and in a soror in
life but even here you have this complex
like these complex mechanics going on
and a lot of it still isn't understood I
mean we can observe it but we really
don't know what's happening at the
atomic level or kind of at the protein
level that allows these things to move
around in such a nicely choreographed
way it's still you know it's still an
area of research some of this is
understood some of it isn't but you have
these two centrosomes and they start
they facilitate the development of these
microtubules which are literally like
these little micro structures you can
view them as as as tubes or as as some
type of of rope
now as prophase progresses it eventually
gets to the point where let me let me do
it on doesn't like this word replication
written here makes it confusing let me
delete that we get rid of this
replication so as prophase progresses
the nuclear envelope actually disappears
so let me redraw this
let me copy and paste what I've done
before put it there because prophase
progresses I'm using to think about
there you go the nuclear envelope
actually starts to to disassemble so
this starts to actually dissolve and
disassemble and then these things start
to grow and attach themselves and attach
themselves to the centromere so actually
let me do that so this is this is all
during prophase is all during prophase
and since all of this happens during
prophase this latter part of prophase
sometimes they'll call it late prophase
sometimes it'll be called prometaphase
actually let me do that let me write
that down
I'll write what I'm Pro metaphase
prometaphase sometimes it's considered I
don't think there's a hyphen really
there let me write pro metaphase so
sometimes it's actually considered a
separate phase of mitosis although when
I learned in school they didn't bother
with prometaphase it just called it all
prophase but by the end of prophase or
actually by the end of prometaphase
depending on how you want to view it the
whole situation is going to look
something like this
you have your overall cell the nuclear
envelope has disassembled so to some
degree it doesn't exist anymore although
the other proteins that formed it are
still there and they're going to be used
later on and you have your two
chromosomes in this case in a human's
case you would have 46 of them you have
your two chromosomes each made with
sister chromatids each made of two
sister chromatids two chromosomes they
of course have their centromeres we're
there right there and then these these
these centrosomes will have migrated
roughly you know roughly on opposite
sides of the of the what was once the
nucleus and these things have kind of
spread apart these microtubules so there
they're doing two functions really at
this point they're kind of pushing these
two centrosomes apart so you have all of
these things and they're connecting the
you know some of them are coming from
this centrosome some are come
from this centrosome some are connecting
the two and then some of these
microtubules these tubes are these ropes
however you want to view them attach
themselves to the centromeres attach
themselves to the centromeres of the
actual chromosomes and the point that
they the protein structure that they
attach them to is called the kinetochore
so there's kinetic over there and that
may or may not be kinetic or it's a
protein structure it's actually
fascinating they're still it's still an
open area of research on how exactly the
microtubule attaches to the kinetic core
and as we'll see in a second it's at the
kinetochore that that the microtubules
essentially start to pull or at the DNA
at the different at the two separate
sister chromatids and actually want and
and actually pull them apart and it's
actually not understood exactly how that
works it's just been observed that this
actually happens once prophase is done
essentially the cells the cells then
just make sure that the chromosomes are
well aligned I mean I kind of drew them
well aligned here but that is kind of
formally occurs during metaphase which
is the next phase so that first of all
it was prophase now we're in metaphase
and metaphase really is just an aligning
of the chromosomes so all of the
chromosomes are going to be aligned at
the center of the cell so I have my
magenta one here I have my magenta one
here I have my and I have my other one
here my green one there and of course
you have your centrosomes the micro
spindles that are coming off of them
some of them are kinetochore
microtubules are actually attaching to
the central the centromeres of the
actual chromosomes it's very confusing
right the centrosome is are these
structures that help direct what happens
to these microtubules centrioles are
these little little structures these
little can shape structures inside the
centrosomes and the centromere are the
center points where the two chromatids
attached to each other within a
chromosome so you know this is one
sister chromatid that's another sister
chromatid and they attach at the
ramier but this is metaphase it's fairly
easy metaphase you just have this
aligning of the cells and there's
actually some theories you know how does
the cell know to progress past this
point how does it know that everything
is aligned and attached is and then
there there are some theories that
there's that there's actually some
signaling mechanism that if one of these
kinetochore proteins aren't properly
attached to one of these ropes that
somehow a signal is sent that the that
mitosis should not continue so this is a
very intricate process that you can
imagine if you have 46 chromosomes and
you have all of this stuff going on in
the cell and you know and you know
there's not like there's some individual
pushing stuff or some computer here it's
all being really directed by by you know
a chemist by chemistry and and
thermodynamic processes but just by the
the intricacy or I guess you know the
the the the elegance of how these things
are it happens spontaneously with all of
the proper checks and balances so that
most of the time nothing bad happens
which is all quite amazing so after
metaphase now we're ready to pull the
stuff apart and that's anaphase and a
phase so in anaphase let me write that
down and a phase I've changed the color
of my cell these guys get pulled apart
and as soon as they get pulled apart so
see this guy is getting pulled let me do
it in green so one of the sister that's
not green one of the sister chromatids
is pulling in that direction one is
getting pulled in that direction and
then same is true for the magenta ones
pull in that direction and one is
getting pulled in that direction and of
course you have your centrosomes here
and then they're connected to the
kinetochores that are right there and
that's where the pulling and there's
also there there's also a whole
microtubule structure that aren't
connect to the actual chromosomes but
they're helping to actually push apart
these two centrosomes so that everything
is going to opposite sides of the cell
and so as soon as as soon as these two
chromatids are separated and I touched
on this a little bit before when we
talked about the
Cabul airy of DNA then as soon as that
happens these are each referred to as
chromosomes so now you can say that the
cell has what it used to have here it
has two chromosomes it now has four
chromosomes because as soon as a
chromatid is no longer connected to its
sister chromatid they're then considered
sister chromosomes which is just a
naming convention I mean they were there
before they were there after they were
just attached before now they're not
attached you kind of considered them
their own individual entity and then
we're almost done the last stage is
telophase the last age is telophase and
I'm going to draw a little the cell a
little bit different here because
something is happening simultaneously
with telophase most of the time so
telophase and actually I'll draw it you
know I'll rotate the cell 90 degrees
let's say that this was one centromere
this is the other centromere so at this
point it's essentially pulled the DNA to
itself so this guy has pulled one of one
copy of that chromosome and one copy of
this chromosome and that guy is done the
same up here he's pulled out he's pulled
over one copy of each used a different
color one copy of each chromosome to
himself now let me draw that right there
like that and now so the nuclear
membrane start forming around each of
these two ends so now you start having a
nuclear membrane form around each of
these two ends and so by the end of the
telophase that's what we're in the
telophase we will have completed mitosis
we will have completely replicated our
two original nucleuses and all of the
genetic content inside of it now at the
same time that telophase is happening
you also normally have this cytokinesis
where this cleavage furrow forms where
essentially during telophase these
things are getting pushed further and
further apart by those microtubules so
that they're always there already at the
ends of the of the of the cell at they
of the cytoplasm of the cell they're all
you can almost feel as pushing on the
sides to elongate the cell and as that
is happening you have this furrow
forming this little indentation and by
the end of telophase in mitosis you all
so have this process of cytokinesis
where this cleavage furrow forms and
deepens deepens deepens until the
cytoplasm is actually split into two
separate cells so this is cytokinesis
which is formally not a part of mitosis
cytokinesis but it normally occurs with
the telophase so right at the end of
mitosis you do normally have to complete
identical cells and then once you have
to each of these two cells then all of
then they each individually enter their
own interphase or they each individually
if we look at just this one he will then
be in his g1 phase and at at some point
these two things are going to replicate
and that's S phase you go to g2 phase
and then this guy will experience
mitosis all over again